as Sri Lanka mourns the death of over
300 people in the Easter Sunday bombings
attention is turning to who might be
responsible the Islamic state says it
was behind the multiple suicide blasts
although it's not offered any proof in a
separate claim a Sri Lankan deputy
governed minister says Sunday's bombings
were carried out in revenge for last
month's attacks on two mosques in New
Zealand fifty people died in that attack
in Christchurch now Sri Lanka's Prime
Minister has just been addressing the
nation on the state of the investigation
let's take a listen I would like to say
that the investigators are making good
progress in regard to identifying the P
culprits but it means that we have to
identify all the culprits and look at
what the network is let's go straight to
Colombo for the very latest
I have journalist Jamila Najmuddin on
the line from there Jamila we just heard
Prime Minister Iranian Vikram a singer
has been talking to the press What did
he say about him this claim from Islamic
state that it was behind this attack
when time in 7 LLL become a singer was
questioned about the Attic the claims
made by Isis today evening he said that
they had heard these names they had seen
it and they were now looking into it
but he also specifically added that
there were suspicions from day number
one that Isis was behind it but
investigators were hoping this link so
is it your understanding that the attack
was carried out by local radical groups
identified by the authorities earlier as
the National toheeb Jamaat and it was
masterminded from outside by so-called
Islamic state reports what we are
hearing is that almost all who have been
arrested a Sri Lankan nationals
unconfirmed reports tell us that there
is one foreign national in Sri Lankan
custody at the moment so it looks like
the attacks has been masterminded by
Isis
it has been carried out by this local
national southeast amat who obviously
now seems to be linked slightly now
Jamilah the Prime Minister talked a pain
about the investigation and he said it
investigations were going well what more
did he say personally I have not
listened heard what the Prime Minister
has said at media briefing I'm hoping to
hear his recording in a short while but
I can tell you what he said in
Parliament today afternoon
he said that investigations had were
going well they had apprehended several
suspects on several more would be
apprehended in the coming days a massive
search operations were going on and he
specifically said that Sri Lanka had
entered the global terror network at
that time he did not say that this group
was linked to Isis but after the Isis
claims now I think the government is
openly admitting that the ISIS had a
hand in it now a deputy government
minister the deputy defense minister
also made some claims that this attack
may have been in revenge for the
Christchurch attacks were tamasa
were targeted what more can you tell us
about this link in Parliament this
initial investigations has revealed that
the attacks carried out on Sunday in Sri
Lanka were in 2002 the Christchurch
attack he however did not get further
details on it but he said further
investigations were going on but he did
say that the international community had
offered assistance to please and the
Prime Minister has also far named
countries like United States Australia
United Kingdom who have come forward to
assist Srilanka and reports we have also
received reports that if the phone is
going to be sending a team here
so that's latest on that right a
journalist H Emilia Najmuddin in the Sri
Lankan capital thank you very much for
being us up-to-date from there thank you
and the country's in shock and people in
Colombo have started burying their dead
a chorus for anemia jaiswal went to
another part of the capital and made a
small community of Christians grieving
for their loved ones a family waiting 49
year-old Shanti went to attend the
Easter service at st. Anthony's Church
they have not heard from her since after
multiple trips to the hospital and even
the mortuary they have not found her
honey made any warmer done than our boys
she went to the church I'm sure that she
always comes home after going to the
church but she never came back she's
still not back we went and searched for
her but we couldn't find her we're still
searching there's no information Saint
Anthony's was one of the eight locations
hit in the serial blasts on Sunday all
around it is a neighborhood in mourning
residents here saw another explosion on
Monday in an abandoned van as people
wait to receive the bodies of friends
and loved ones they silently contemplate
their own survival a few feet from the
site of two blasts as locals here
prepare for funerals they tell us that
the death toll in the neighborhood could
have been much higher but for the
practice that people closer to the
church attend services on Saturday
evening and on Sunday morning people who
live further away attend services the
blasts hit on Easter which was a Sunday
morning this is a mixed neighborhood
people from all religions reside here
many resident Muslims and Hindus pitch
in to help local Christians are unable
to understand the carnage Ningaloo say
this is new for us even during the time
of the Tamil Tigers we weren't targeted
even the tsunami didn't damage this area
these attacks of chartres sad duke are
disputed a this is so sad today is
Tuesday we usually
go to Mass but the church is closed for
Sri Lankans and especially residents of
this neighborhood were very sad but
sadness and anger have to be put on hold
to bid farewell to those who were lost
today Colombo has come together to mourn